starting your own tournaments on chest
coms live server whether you want to
play blitz standard chess960 or any one
of our variants is now possible and
incredibly easy let's start this
tutorial first by switching to my
favorite left-side navigation if you're
not using it remember one of the main
reasons that it gives you more room in
the middle of the screen if you're
analyzing things allows your board to be
a little bit bigger if you're scrolling
through articles or news reports allows
you to see a little more of the most
important part of the screen I'm gonna
collapse the menu and then I'm gonna go
into the play and enter the live chess
server now once in the live chest server
of course the fastest way to get a game
is to just choose your game type and and
then choose your time control and press
play but the tournaments tab is where
you will find the ability to start your
own live Club tournament I click on this
tab and rather than enter one of the
tournaments getting set to start I'll
click club tournament in this situation
I am actually allowed to start a
tournament for any club than I am the
administrator for if you're a member of
the club and you would like to be an
admin of a club simply create your own
club make yourself the admin and then
invite your friends to join let's set
the club as Danny's first live
tournament the club I'm going to use
will be a small club Danny wrench fan
club not too many people in there will
play standard let's play bullet today
why not I'll set the start time for
today it's set right now for about five
o'clock
that should work it's about an hour from
when I'm recording this video minimum
number of players we will say is 11 and
we'll say 12 maximum number of players
is 100 rounds we'll set it to 10 or I'm
sorry that was the minimum rating
minimum rating we will put at 300 so
anybody can play and make the maximum
rating 3000 minimum players we will do
as I said 12 players up to 100 click
create and as you can see the link to
join my tournament has been added to the
upcoming tournaments list
not everybody will see that only members
of this club will see the ability to
enter and join this tournament so it's
not the best idea to start a tournament
and then try to invite members to your
club usually the other way around should
be the way you go about things however
as the functionality for this tool
improves look for the ability to start a
tournament and then send a direct link
to anyone on the web clicking it will
allow them to enter their tournament
even as a guest member on chess comm
just one of the many things we are
working on there you have it that is
exactly how you start a club tournament
in live chess choose your poison pick
any type of game variance or standard
bullet or blitz and get started right
here is exactly where you can see the
chat for the tournament as I hold over
tournament chat I can say hi everyone
welcome and as they come in and register
they can all engage in the same chat the
tournament will start automatically at
the server requested time that I did so
5:00 p.m. Pacific and I look forward to
playing my first tournament very soon
thanks for watching